technologically we can say the chinese
military is modern it is probably one of
the best equipped militaries in the
world but we don't know how they work as
a as a team as a unit so we can't really
fully assess how they would
end up fighting how they would perform
in a war the last time china went to war
with 1970s and that didn't go very well
for them we don't have good data for
that part of the equation it's really
difficult to assess how capable they are
the chinese military has been through a
really big reform process since sort of
the 1980s it's been trying to make
itself more modern and more capable to
address the norms of warfare that it
observes as it looks out towards the
world the most notable aspect really of
it is their ship building program no
country on earth can build ships at the
rate that china is this is a 30-40 year
process that's still ongoing it's still
evolving they're not there yet the goal
is
for becoming a world-class military on a
par with the us the pla ground force
plays a really important role because it
is sort of the senior force and it
always has been because it is the force
that founded the pla it's the force that
won the revolution in the 1940s is the
force that has provided security for a
really long time because a lot of
china's threats are actually on its land
border broadly we can look back over
china's history and there are long
periods of humiliation
at the hands of western powers if we
look at the boxer rebellion the uk
flood of opium into china taking control
of the chinese markets destroying the
chinese navy things like that haven't
sat particularly well the point is that
they felt for a long time that they
couldn't really keep invaders at arm's
reach
taiwan plays a big part for a lot of
different reasons it's obviously a
democracy which the u.s tries to support
and uphold it's important because it has
u.s support attached to it and china
doesn't agree with that china doesn't
see taiwan as a country it just sees
taiwan as an extension of china there
are a lot of territorial disputes in
that region
secondly there are a lot of security
concerns and the us provides a balancing
effect to both at the moment and if the
us isn't able to provide it it would
have to come from china at present a lot
of countries in the region are relying
upon china economically but militarily
only towards the us if they were to
begin to lean towards china militarily
as well as economically then the us's
influence in the region gets degraded
and so that's sort of the long-term
picture of it it's not a cataclysmic
collapse it's an erosion of u.s
influence
you